welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
after dark this is where we get
ranch dirty wild
and totally uncensored
because we don't give a freak anything
why because of all our gracious members
that support the show
make this episode possible and here we
are yet again
after dark number two they said
[Applause]
they said we wouldn't last after number
two but here we are in number six
you know and uh once again they're wrong
now here's i have a couple of things i
need to get to first of all
i don't know why we're all wearing
sunglasses is everyone wearing
sunglasses
was that yeah yeah so my first thing is
yes i am number one on wiki feet
as you all know i have shattered
what was previously thought possible on
the website
here let me pull it up wiki feet
ethan klein dude i am like
seven out of five do you understand how
insane that is you guys
did you get up to seven yeah
did you break seven wait i got i didn't
get rid of this though i want to smell a
few
i didn't break seven but it's so close
bro i don't even know if it's possible
it's like the speed barrier i mean how
much higher can you go
you know it's like it's like 6.92 out of
five it doesn't make sense already
right you know
that's not so here's what i want to do
is i want to get a
because you know any time you show your
foot they and somebody throws it
it's like yeah so i want to get a shot
of me
in the wiki hat showing my feet
for the um you know just just to
recognize the wicked feet community
yeah so here you go people this is for
wikifeet okay
here actually use this one please how's
the shot
can i see the shot i can't see it yeah
how does it look
you're getting it it's all in there baby
okay
now speaking of um
speaking of wikifeet people started
from the general wikifee community
finding
that you know i was the number one most
popular male
on the whole of the website and they
we started getting comments
of people who are just confused you can
tell that they're real wikifeet uh
denzians is that the right word denzin
denizen
denizen white that could be wrong too i
don't know where what
okay wait these are so small i just want
to be able to read that oh god
dan why can't i read these do the
magnifying glass thingy
i am a well-respected foot enthusiast i
am very offended
by accusations of false rating wait what
oh this one's in support
okay okay something is happening here
look at their icon oh that's weird a
heart with
feet that's just weird he's been a
member since 2018 so
don't question him there's some straight
up
weirdos on the internet looks like a lot
of fans are making accounts just so they
can give them five stars i mean this
dude's currently at a 6.4
actually 7.9 or 6.9
higher than sean mendes chris hemsworth
zac efron
and justin bieber who are rightly or
wrongly
the undisputed kings of wikifeed men
this guy's feet are average as hell uh
well the rating says otherwise
[ __ ] by the way look at his username
foot slave
82 notice that so shout out to foot
slave 82
where is foot slave number one
question what happened to flood slave
number one hey
they're not good feet at all uh feet
sniff that's his name
how dare you
how dare you [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out let's see
yeah it's just raiding he's saying i'm
ruining the website
well that's just your opinion bro
perhaps there is something that the
moderators can do
like wipe suspend bro i'm putting your
website on the map
how dare you suggest that came across
this guy's feet due to his rating
currently being the highest on the site
how did that happen
but i have to say i love the flat
worn out appearance uh oh plus a smelly
looking tan oh great shot for
analyzing by the way overall a
well-deserved rating am i waiting
you see we won over that's a really
legit review
you can tell yeah he's talking about the
tan of the smelliness but this guy
actually
i'm you do have a flat foot right i
guess so
you saw it all yeah you read right
leaves bro that guy actually supports me
though like that's
so cool now these are some of the cutest
little piggies i've
ever seen
[Laughter]
piggy these are the best feet i've ever
seen in my entire life that's got to be
a
supporter this this is the only person
we've won over who
i think is from the general how long
were they a member that's how you can
tell
well unfortunately this guy's just been
a member since this month three days ago
yeah i wish you didn't ask me that
sorry anyway so there's a lot of motion
over there on wiki feed
and now when everyone finds me number
one they'll see me in the hat with the
thumbs up
mostly for the mods of the site so that
they don't remove you they gotta see
that you're
your financial supporter of the website
oh someone said
a food model reviewed ethan's fit on
youtube
what model
um you know what i'm doing guys because
i'm so
i'm i'm obviously fat and i've got gerd
so either
either made me talk to a nutritionist
and i'm drinking smoothies now i mean
i'm helping you no it's made of me
okay well you no it's good you're right
you're good i know i'm drinking
smoothies now i'm having
two of these a day what's in the
smoothie
it's [ __ ] great unheard of
ingredients it's like a bunch of lettuce
and like
one banana to sweeten it and um
pea protein it's kind of cool it's not
that bad you got this in there
little pea little little bit of my own
urine
that's hot just a dash and
um that's the way to go so i have two of
these
one in the morning one in the afternoon
then i have one meal one healthy meal
that's really cool but he said you know
you learn a lot talking to nutritionists
he's like uh
i know we had like a big debate a long
time ago about diet coke
he says diet coke can make you or you
absorb
sugar later after you've drank it but he
did say it's better than
normal soda but he could be a quack too
i mean he's just a [ __ ] guy found on
the internet
he seemed knowledgeable though yeah he
did he did he has a degree in chip
but i only paid i feel i pa he was like
150 150 is that a lot it didn't seem
like a lot
first time how much time an hour hour
150 an hour but he's got like a degree
in [ __ ] i don't know
uh who cares this is all the farce yeah
i don't really anyway let's talk about
zach's birthday has arrived zach um
we bought zach a gift zach would you
like to open your gift
uh yes um don't dox yourself
oh yeah good call here i want to watch
hang on this is such a schlep every time
okay go ahead zach
this is exciting everybody
get pumped we bought zach the perfect
gift hooters gift card
nice too
for the man you know it's funny wow
go ahead give your acceptance speech oh
thank you so wow two hooters gift cards
shrimp burgers and salads wait you
actually
know the menu there no it just says it
on the gift card
i don't know how many times you've been
there bro i've been doing hooters uh
once in my life and um it was a pleasant
experience it seems embarrassing to eat
it
i mean
was the food good uh food was all right
boobs were better
gotcha that's why we got you there
that's why we got it for you
well thank you guys very much i
appreciate it
happy birthday you know on amazon you
could only buy
they maxed out at 50. which i don't know
if that says something about hooters
but that's the max gift card you could
get so we're going
thank you i appreciate it all right have
fun these are gonna go to good use
have a good time all right oh um
huff okay donated a thousand something i
don't know if
that's probably not dollars but he said
love the hair thank you and he said have
you seen the social dilemma
dilemma how do you say it and we have i
was actually
i asked everyone else to watch it
because i got really freaked out
um right it's like they're like oh
social media sucks it's [ __ ] ruining
everyone's life
we're the people that made it i worked
at facebook
i worked at instagram and take it from
me so we made it
explicitly to [ __ ] your brain up but we
got out
after we made a bunch of money and now
we're making money again by making a
documentary about it that's all right
that's kind of
my takeaway as well either in lectures
and
how about you go [ __ ] off
get the [ __ ] out of my face but it's
still so scary
because i really feel like i i have a
problem where like
it slowly happened and now it's like
i'm always on my phone and i don't even
do anything i'm not even that active on
social media
and somehow i'm still all day on my
phone you know what i do and maybe it'll
help you
before i open a social media app now
lately i say
okay is there anything important i need
to check in here
and if not because you get it's because
it's like compulsive it's like
yeah you just and it and then you the
thing is you're looking for something
good
and but you never find it you know on
tick tock
i kind of spend way less time on
instagram
which is good i hate instagram
instagram's the worst i spent
a lot of time on instagram yeah you
think instagram's the worst well
honestly
twitter is the most toxic i feel like
twitter is the most because yeah for me
for me twitter i can just check in real
fast and get out
you know what i mean i check in
but it's like why do i even check in
then it's like i can't control it
i don't even like anything that i see on
there to me tick-tock is
wholesome because at least because like
at least i'm watching something and i'm
being entertained
but on tick tock on twitter you're like
what am i even doing
yeah twitter you're like i'm literally
just
i'm like vacuuming i'm like
what am i doing you're like a hamster on
a wheel hey twitter world
hey twitter world this is yours truly
anyway i like hey twitter world this is
yours it's true tuck is my home
are you getting a tech tacula i am i i
like the fashion
side of it um you would
yeah so yeah tick tock is our home
there's this uh yeah i'm following a few
people
like people that's the start you know
yeah
excuse me um okay
let's start the show oh we have a new
collection on teddy fresh really just
really fast
it's a epic collab i think i i say this
too
much but i think these are the best
pieces we've ever made
um dan bortz is it borts
just because it's his name yes then
isaac bortz
is artist that i found on instagram
i love following all these artists on
instagram because i feel like it's such
a
new thing like compared to art galleries
and having to go
to exhibitions and all that it's like
we all just follow everything on
instagram and um
they get to sell their art independently
they don't have to pay 50
to a gallery and so i just love art on
instagram i think it's a great thing
and i discovered a lot of people like
that um and this guy
i actually found also because post
malone originally
commissioned art from him for clothing
for clothing because he's been wearing a
lot of like one-offs people will
actually draw on his stuff
and then boards did a really amazing one
for him
and so we i reached out and he was down
to do it
and that was a long time ago we've been
working on it for a while
it was so long ago but the thing is like
technically
this piece is really cool it was kind of
because it was actually what was with
this picture i don't like this picture i
was like
i don't want to say but the photo shoot
went weird it's like why we have a guy
shirtless we're trying to sell clothes i
guess it's for the painting it's the
photographer
it's for the pants decision but it's
like hello we're selling clothes
why are you not wearing a top
what the [ __ ]
anyway these are the conversations we
have behind the scenes
but uh he drew a bunch of stuff on his
sketchbooks and he sent it to us and
uh when i saw it i was like for me i
really want to like
go all in on this so we wanted to like
incorporate
embroidery with puffy paint with patches
and just do like do it all the way
and it wasn't easy because it just um
it can end up looking kind of shitty if
it's not done right
so it came out amazing we worked on it
like here's one detail for example like
here's this is puffy paint and this is
an embroidery
yeah and it it really just looks like
his art
so i mean the prop and then like this is
puffy paint
with a gradient here and then this is an
embroidery
the dice and it's just this is all
embroidered
uh it just came out like so true to
to his art that uh i'm stoked
so that's that all right let's talk
let's let's talk about something else
okay
i am the highest in the room when you
get it uh
uh on tick tock you start getting all
these weird songs in your head yeah like
super weird [ __ ] that
maybe it's not weird maybe it's
mainstream and i just never heard this
[ __ ] before
all right
okay can i talk about james charles one
last time uh
but it's in the document so i have to
why do you guys set me up
i've been over your document i
am the okay here's okay i'm just gonna
do this fast
hi my name is james charles and i say
i've never
heard of teddy fresh or i've never seen
your brand
and i've nev i don't know anything about
your brand
you guys are [ __ ] and i've never
heard of your [ __ ] brand
flash cut his best friend larry
how do by the way how do you say his
name it's kind of larray
is it larae oh larae that makes sense
i'm an [ __ ]
by the way i'm just reading english like
larry
larae well i don't know anymore so
i don't know either i'm just reading
okay good everybody's happy for you hilo
you know how to read
anyway by the way that that that that
shout out to larae because you know he's
a fan of our clothing obviously and
you know i hate to bring him into this
but regardless
uh larae is here seen wearing teddy
fresh
la rae is here seeing
wearing teddy fresh and a now famous
meme by the way
this is a meme that has made its rounds
the caption is always something like me
30 minutes into my 15-minute lunch break
[Laughter]
yeah i love this picture it's great man
i even know it's the same person but
then
when we posted it we actually didn't
even know that it was like a famous
person
because we posted it on instagram what
we posted that as a meme we didn't even
know who he was and then we found out
and um that's the story so that's him
great story anyway the point is that
there's zero [ __ ] chance
that james charles doesn't know who the
[ __ ]
doesn't know that that's our hoodie okay
now the reason i bring this up is
because he's already selling it
and he's selling a trillion of them and
by the way i've already heard people
saying they post a picture of them in
the color block and they go oh you
already got your sister marsh i swear to
god
i swear to god hey yeah hi sisters
my sister and so now and and i'm just
i'm just being honest with you people
now who are wearing color block hoodies
no don't say it
yeah okay stop their sister
stop it hi sisters
i have to say i was neutral on james
charles now i really dislike him
i hate him hate him
i really do he's such a phony baloney
all right slow down
he's a phony baloney and he's making
don't like it billy
not only well i don't even care he's
making a billion dollars
it's that he's making our brand look
like
[ __ ] sister merch okay
what's your next topic oh okay you know
that
what was that what ai in
i was just saying that's kind of funny
i've had the opposite experience
when you become a massive fan
you were saying uh what was your
opposite experience
you've started to like them less and
less i've liked them more and more
[Music]
i actually kind of made a big purchase
yesterday i'm you know
pretty excited about it from this
website you got the sister mark got all
the yeah
they call it the no oh man oh but i
can't see should i be seeing oh you
should be seeing this
oh man yeah yeah that's a lot of money
70 000 what the [ __ ] dude what
wait you were just complaining about
money the other and the content
that's why you're complaining about
money seventy thousand dollars bro
thank you a.i.a i have a bit of a
confession
i i accidentally uh might have used your
card
[Laughter]
if i was you i would just be mining
bitcoins or something yeah yeah and have
you
just i kind of just viewed it as an
advance that i should have received so
okay you want to be so you want to be
paid in sister merch from now on
how about some tatty merch
i'll take it all right okay good good
can i get some commemorative incense
sticks to put in my background
have you developed uh telepathic powers
or something because
your mouth isn't moving it's kind of
interesting that we can hear you oh what
uh uh
[Music]
i might have to go to autozone for a
quick repair
did it already break man
what's the next topic i'll be back
oh it's gone wait should we should we
explain how
were we going to explain ain today what
do you
explain what what do you mean the behind
the scenes
i don't think it was today was it but
it's not ready no
all right
[Laughter]
all right so let's get on with it then
dublin
oh this one's real weird dude so this
guy dublin
you can queue him up zach he wants to
teach me how to
do mongolian throat singing and he
thinks
that due to my gerd
i would be good at it he's also a he has
a bs in physics and a p
he's a phd student right now here's a
video
he gets really technical this is really
fascinating stuff here
dublin is this is this is it
he thinks i could do this
[Music]
i don't need lessons
yeah exactly it's got like more uh
wavy you know what i mean so
how he gets really worried about it he
says ethan has a sub
tone a tone below the main pitch being
heard
as well as a very present harmonic that
means he has activated the vestibular
vest that means he's activating the
vestibule
vestibular bueller
dd mega doom vestibular folds as well as
the vocal cords because the vestibular
folds vibrate
at a lower frequency i.e he is doing
karga the throat singing style here is a
link
to my what my vocal cords do he's
oh this is what it does if you're
curious and want to be
this is worse than pimple pop yeah
i mean what is this supposed to prove i
mean yeah
so it it's how uh wide or uh
constricted your vocal cords how am i
supposed to know how wide or constricted
vocal chords supposed to look like
just looks disgusting i mean it looks
like a
colonoscopy
oh and then finally
wait what oh this guy's such a legend
bro i love this guy
incoming viral hog clan
[Music]
so what this guy's claiming is that i am
like the king arthur of
mongolian throat singing that i just
have to pick up
excalibur i was born for this let's go
wait where's this there was a video of
him like i like when he said you
activated something
sounds like yeah i've activated my
[ __ ] level exactly here
here he even put my voice into some kind
of audio
uh program to show that my pitch is
jedi level perfect
so this is one of your coughs slowed
down apparently
this is actually the cough from your 100
t-shirt video
and he isolated and slowed it down
all right bring him in let's do this
okay dragging him in right now
he's on dublin
can you hear me yes yes dublin
dublin or duke dublin dublin dublin
why is it that you've got this interest
in mongolian throat singing
well i'm i'm a musician i've
been i started on saxophone and
i got into choir as well like my whole
family is musical
and so when i uh and they're the kind of
nerds to have
seen mongolian throat singers live and
so then that's kind of what got me into
it
and then yeah i just really liked this
carcias style
um and yeah so and you didn't show the
video of uh where i
like decomposed the frequencies but
um yeah you're already a throat singer
you just don't know it
singer seems like a euphemism for like
deep throating of a
giant [ __ ] you're good you're a throat
singer buddy you just don't know here
dublin you want to give us an example uh
you want to do something yeah
yeah let's hear
keep doing that meanwhile just keep
doing that and i'll put this on the
screen
[Music]
so vin diesel's actually turned on by
this
i'm not surprised you know i read that
women
actually prefer men who can throat sing
really
they say it makes your voice like the
timbre of your voice
more desirable oh so not
not you know i did find your voice uh
very cool what thank you i appreciate
thank you
so what why would you say that live like
this i'm just kidding
all right well so you're saying not
everybody can throat sing
no no no anyone can throat sing i think
it's more of a
if you throat sing you develop this
control
over your vocal cords that turns your
voice
more desirable i mean i don't know if i
believe it that's just what i read
was that written by you
could send you a yeah it was uh like how
to throat sing.com or something okay
all right let's let let's start the uh
tutorial what do what how do we do this
so the the first thing you need to do is
don't try and sing
so when you were singing to the um
the the mongolian guy you're you're just
using your vocal cords
also known as the vocal fold but when
you throat sing
you activate uh the
ventricular folds as well as the vocal
folds so start by just like clearing
your throat
like just go like ah
he's very good at that yeah he's got a
lot of problems you're really good
and and then so just like try and keep
doing that and then try and like there's
a tone in there and
like think of like making motorcycle
noises like
yeah so you're trying to sing uh
so that's like a regular note right
it's more like you take them
don't see anything just cough just do
what you've been doing
it's in there it's so beautiful what
what else can i do i
i feel like i've reached the peak of
understanding
i feel like i've understood mongolian
throat singing they're saying it's
gerd opera
[Laughter]
that's funny yeah how do you feel about
being characterized as gerd oprah
well i mean i actually do have a little
bit of gerd myself
one time i went to the hospital
boys nerd gang
so am i yeah it correctly
so that that is normal singing oh it is
don't try and sing a note don't try and
sing a particular note
just try and i'm not elongate that
coughing
ah yeah that's it
so how do you but like how do you
breathe if you want to keep the note
going
we just have to breathe it just takes
practice to do it for a long time
because i don't know how to it would
stop
yeah you'll feel a pressure in your
throat and it's it's like you saw how
constricted that guy's throat was doing
it right
the larynx is really constricted so
it'll feel like a lot of pressure
and you just gotta like kind of force
that air like trying
like you know when you um it's called a
glottal stop when you go like
so try and like feel that same sort of
pressure when you're doing the throat
singing
[Music]
yeah that's really
[Music]
but wait i feel like this sounds better
when i go
like why do i have to do it like i'm
choking
now maybe i don't know exactly what
you're doing because that sounded really
good
try that again whatever you did in the
end
like you pushed more air through it and
then it the tone chain
oh there you go something's been diesel
now
oh talk to me
that is baby the technique so then
you just gotta like keep doing that
it'll your throat will start to hurt at
first so then
stop when it hurts everyone's trying to
get home
everyone's trying to help so make sure
you don't hurt your throat
trying to stop and come back 10 minutes
later
um yeah women can do it there's no
reason
for you to not try it too good
[Music]
yeah i'll keep the tone going and then
you you
okay go ahead um
talk to me baby
that's a good question wow all right
all right thank you dublin dublin thank
you so much you are a
road you are a throat
you're
congratulations man thanks so much for
having me on
thanks man i appreciate you thank you
doug for calling yeah
i want to see my girlfriend and i have
loved your content for many years we
love teddy fresh so yeah don't stop
thank you man appreciate you love you
keep going congrat keep get that phd
dude
bring it in yeah bring that throat thing
into the world all right god bless
i tried to do it for a second and i just
i immediately started
it hard to throw yeah it's horrible oh
my throat's been through
way worse i guess he was right about
[Laughter]
that whatever
i feel like that yeah that guy's got a
talent
all right y'all you guys know we talked
about 90 day fiance
a lot now i don't know how many you how
follow how close you guys follow
but there was one couple in particular
that was like such a [ __ ] show
his name was um colt culty
called t and larissa and he's like this
big
goofy uh dude who went and got a girl
from like columbia and she's a total hot
[ __ ] mess this is them
okay you may remember them from 90 today
oh and he lives with his mom who's like
super possessive here's
him and his mom and she's like
controlling his life they have the same
a bank account and loretta's
his girlfriend's like i don't understand
why larissa is like
you have to share the bank account with
your mom and she the mom was like making
him choose between him and her
and she hated his mom that was the best
the best
couple yeah you guys at home probably
remember she's got so much plastic
surgery now it's crazy
she just did she had the lips and stuff
and she just did
boobs and nose at the same time yeah she
was
she was at the doctor and she goes fake
as pos they go what do you want your
boobs look like
fake as possible apparently that's the
thing now
she's also uh i feel like that's a new
trend
like to want the boobs to look fake
because i remember when
they were working really hard on making
them look natural yeah the doctor was
like [ __ ] we worked for 20 years to make
them look natural
what zack um she actually
recently she's a cam model now like
uh at home cam pornstar well
congratulations to her
she uh she made a hundred thousand
dollars in one hour
wow everyone on the one on the website
dude i gotta start killing my butthole
online or something because like there's
so much money and just
only fans type of content you know
you already put it out there for free on
twitter
you know what this what they what's that
saying and it's very chauvinistic so
please
forgive me the difference between a
[ __ ] and a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] gets paid for it so i'm a [ __ ]
i'm just god i'm just trying to say i'm
a [ __ ]
really i i didn't make up the saying
because okay whatever i'll move on
[Laughter]
i get you ethan yeah thank you no
problem
it's way worse than it has to be
oh um someone is saying teresa did say
you go where the money is so
that's true she did say that well
well i would way rather these girls be
making the money than like
these [ __ ] psycho porn industry big
shots who are like
the people who earn points porn sites
generally from what i've seen are like
the sleaziest people
in the world so the girls are now making
the they're getting rich making money
doing their own thing and
that's awesome you know
so anyway guess who's on only fans
not larissa
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] coltie
colti is on only fans
i can't i gotta i gotta find the uh
does this guy this guy right here he's
on only fans
okay now zach went in there
zach is our resident porn scooper
yes i am how much did it cost it's 25
a month wow and did you were you able to
beat off to this
way no okay i have to ask
no i have to ask and did you find that
you got your money well spent
i mean you've seen them what do you
think
i'm asking you um i think for the the
humor
aspect of it 150 now there's a real
well here there's a real question at
hand here
what okay hang on let me pull these up
the question is well at 25 you have to
assume
that what you're seeing here is serious
right
let's see here he says the man the myth
the legend having appeared on a
record-shattering amount of
television record shattering i really
doubt that
colt johnson has become an international
icon beloved by
millions now for the first time only
you'll get a deeper look into his
private moments and get to know him on
an intimate level you'll never forget
by the way he lives with his mom and
like a duplex
i just love that he's like beloved by
millions the legend
record shattering he's just in a duplex
with his mom in las vegas
but i don't know if he still lives with
him yeah he does
you think so you think she would support
of this
i don't think she [ __ ] i do what do i
know they're so weird yeah yeah i think
so
he makes the money so here's a here's
this is the kind of thing you get for 25
a month and again it's like i just can't
tell if he's
if he's serious or not but like you have
to assume he is
if you're charging what's in the shot
like the dark this the beverage no at
the bottom
oh good question good question
oh it's a cat i see the cat here
but like anyone can make money on only
fans
look at this [ __ ] are you [ __ ] are
you serious right now bro
and he's sure to get the feet in there
too good
good good good i love the tan stinky
what'd they say
the tan stinky part
yeah i tapped that i don't know about
you either but i'd [ __ ] ride that
man i used to i watched this
[ __ ] season and now to see his
ask some only fans is truly a trip
i mean here we go george costanza baby
can we show this it's a man in underwear
why not
okay i mean it's just a guy in like a
swimsuit
true this one he's wearing it but like
this like look at i mean tell me what
the [ __ ] am i supposed to think about
this whoops
hang on what am i supposed to do with
this
you didn't jerk off no people are asking
if we're allowed to show these so
yeah we have to go down we headed to
what because it's i mean we had a debate
about this paywall content
yeah i think so i mean
well promoting it's commentary
like you can comment on things behind a
paywall
yeah but can you show it that's
different than commenting on it
of course you have to show it to comment
on it
well i don't know can you review a movie
dan
sure movie reviews they don't show the
movie
they show clips of the movie oh that's
true oh fair enough
i mean i'm not sure photos these photos
debate and then why are you coming on
here playing like
prosecutor me yeah well
and the chat's talking about it yeah but
come on
here you guys didn't back me up
yesterday what'd you say yesterday
oh yes i was saying i don't think we can
oh my god you guys are really going to
do this now
i think we can do it well that's not
what we already did so there you go
i think i think i think what matters is
that you don't
show all of them and that you provide a
necessary commentary which i think we've
done
and here i would definitely jerk off i
love how
much whipped cream is used he's got
great fupa too
yeah really nice so there you have it
you guys ruined the bit
here let me look at the all the other
ones and then just decide if there's
if there's other good ones to show
because this one like this one here
super weird like why would he include
this
he's just doing like crunches daddy
chill
oh my god oh my god
all right you guys have seen enough yeah
so there you go i mean if you're
interested in his only fans
oh here's my favorite part you guys he
has an amazon wishlist bro
do you understand what i'm saying on his
own
so that his sims can buy him [ __ ] well
maybe we should buy him some stuff
yeah i was thinking that i was support
not supporting so wait
here can i show this on the screen i
mean i don't think there's anything
wrong with this
did you open an incognito or something
because i don't know
here let me open this in incognito so
that
people don't hack me his amazon wishlist
yeah
but i guess this is something a lot of
like e girls do
they are i don't know i don't know who
does this i think just e-girls
where they have like an amazon wishlist
yeah well he's not a girl
well he's an e-boy he's an e-boy so
let's look at his wish list because it
is pretty captivating
stainless steel table heavy duty
commercial kitchen prep ware it doesn't
say how much it is on this
yeah it does 134 dollars no [ __ ] me
wow how about a beetlejuice the complete
series i love it dvd set
the the cartoon from the next wait look
at the next one
um portable wood fire outdoor pizza oven
300 bro what are you gonna do with all
this crap are you serious
i put like groceries i feel like a bag
of rice
thing existed a portable peach element
yeah it's on his wish list
you know what i mean it should be like
bag of goya beans
20 pounds like let's stock up you know
let's get some useful [ __ ]
it's great though isn't it pizza is
actually very nutritious wait how many
pizzas holy [ __ ]
dude what is
he has no pizza experience let's see
this is a mop a bucket floor cleaning
system with two extra refills see that's
what i'm talking about
let's get useful here let's get you
something so funny about this
random like everyday objects being
related to only fans like
so not sexy groundhog day on blu-ray
uncle buck the wolves of wall street
well what do you want to pick him up we
should buy him i love the spin mop
i think we should buy him the mop
definitely it's a lot of movies
bro okay chill jesus i mean the the
pizza oven is like a big i'm not buying
his ass a 300
pizza oven
he's never been in the pizza you know
what i would buy it for mila but i know
he'll never use it
what he'll never use it he put two of
them on the list
that's all about it do you think he's a
pizza guy
i mean i think you should write from one
pizza guy to another
i'm not gonna never i would never play
pizza for [ __ ] sake
you should get him the chuck norris dvd
pizza recognizes pizza really i was
thinking uncle buck
okay let's buy him first of all let's
definitely buy him the mop
yeah but let's buy off school yeah so
add that i'll add the mop
and let's get him you guys think we
should get him uh
uncle buck you guys were thinking uncle
buck yeah yeah
yeah oh the table
the table was expensive too wasn't it
140 bucks
well we could just buy him the table i'm
prepared to do that well we got to get
the mop too
table in the mock table in the morning
[ __ ] the [ __ ] up
so if he can't come yo you guys can't
complain anymore like about this
only fans [ __ ] we're about to drop
200 on the table
[Music]
my bank bro all right let's get him
we're gonna buy him the table we're
gonna owe him that was like some of the
greatest content
on television the season with him and
larissa
oh it's like a tip for for ruining his
life for
what i didn't ruin his life but
all right let me add it to my car i'm
going to buy it right now because i
don't want to say i'm going to do it
his mom was taking the pictures and show
the rest
his mom took the picture oh god you're
right his mom
took the picture yeah that's from the
chat no it has to be
that that's what happened
all right so i'm adding the cart right
and yes nick this is where your
membership money is going
i'm adding the mop
[Laughter]
and then you guys said i'm a member you
guys said what what else
and it's going to be the bucks actually
not available ooh robocop
are waiting for all buying see i gotta
get in the matrix now i gotta buy some
aftermarket uncle buck
all right here uncle block no i'm not
buying this [ __ ] i don't like buying
from weird vendors
all right the the table in the mop is
plenty the table and the mop guys don't
be greedy all right so let me see what's
in our card here
okay we are looking at 180
180 bucks h3 out of context said his mom
put the whipped cream
on probably as well i think he's right i
mean
well he well oh no oh i don't know my
login dan do you know the login for the
can you come type in the password i have
to buy it now
it's important for for your amazon
amazon
it says h it says it's the podcast one
oh
jeez do you know the password i didn't
even make this one i don't it's
it's we have to do it live otherwise
we'll never do it
it's true i'll do it right now that's
true where's the list okay either you're
on it i just want to see the
confirmation
so that we can prove that we bought it
where is our document
in the meantime i will move on yeah move
on okay okay
some donations real quick yes please
please please please all right can
someone send me the link to his uh
attendance somebody send it to her on
the discord
yeah okay cool um yeah uh donations
let's see let's see let's see
uh let's see 50 donation from jacob i'm
a
former military police officer and
decided not to pursue a civilian police
job because of today's injustice okay
thanks for helping me through life well
you're welcome
jacob stay safe uh thank you brother
let's see um simpleton
donated 50 uh dkk i think that might be
danish
what is a chrome chrome it is chrome
uh please don't do more videos with
trisha she's obviously just
using you for exposure and is the least
interesting person i have ever seen and
that is
definitely not happening simpleton but
thank you for watching what the [ __ ]
well i appreciate the concern
i love making the show with her and uh
we will continue until it's a hit too
it's in one of us
either one of us is killed by each other
her most likely will do the murder
all right has anyone actually died from
corona
[Laughter]
why is it it's asking me to put in a
shipping address
isn't it supposed to be like it's his
wishlist it's supposed to know what the
[ __ ] go to your car
you can't check out if i go
check out yeah then
it's asking for a shipping address maybe
it's just a receipt
or hmm what well
because you don't they don't want to
give you his address right
there's no way to just anonymously shift
i don't want i if this
bucket and table comes to my [ __ ]
house so i think he
wants you to get the address from him
because
he probably doesn't want to lick his own
address but that's how the wish list i
thought the wishlist just anonymously
sent it to him
does chat know how this [ __ ] works it
says some amazon customers
have allowed us to share their shipping
addresses with third-party
merchants a b knows what what is it baby
yeah it's supposed to be anonymous like
yeah
once you make the purchase i just did it
for my cousin's baby shower
thing so why is this so why is his wife
maybe he configured it wrong that seems
here let's
let someone else yeah all right somebody
else will figure out in the meantime uh
braille 20 i demand h3 staff play among
us and stream it i keep hearing about
this game i haven't played it have any
of you guys
played among us no it's very popular i
see it everywhere
it's like a collaborative like whodunnit
game i think yeah it's
one of you is is uh secretly uh
like sabotaging everybody i played a
bunch of board games that have the same
concept um
where like one person is randomly
selected to be like the evil one and
nobody knows who it is and the whole
game is
figuring out which one of the people is
uh sabotaging i don't know i'll look
into it maybe that could be fun
yeah it could be fun to play that
together yeah uh
claire 23 hey ethan and ela it's my 23rd
birthday i love you guys in the gang
your episodes truly bright my day
hashtag gerd gang happy birthday claire
happy birthday claire claire claire
claire
looking for some other big ones uh
everything moves too fast i don't know
if you want to move on
i can get some more later okay here's a
channel called gaston bro
it's called gaston all right
need i say more uh no need i say more to
you all right here right now
get [ __ ] gassed on bro
it's called chick blast farts and
leggings what the [ __ ] is that
get gassed on haters
[Music]
wait don't don't sound bad that was that
here i just want to read the comments
because
i think maybe it's too graphic to show
so i just want to let you guys enjoy the
sound
of this this is what you're seeing and
i'll read the comments
those moans after she lets loose are so
sexy
oh we have we have a time stamp here
let's see what it is oh yeah that's that
was a good one
[Laughter]
i dedicate my life to being her
underwear right now
i lost it i think i want to marry this
woman or you want to hear where he lost
it
4 10.
some i don't hear distinct i love how
they timestamp their favorite farts
isn't that epic
they're getting sick who else what do
they mean lost it like jizz
are they just like oh i'm an ecstasy
let's hear 701 let's see
oh that was good i lost it bro
how do you prepare for a session like
that
that's a good question well some people
some people can fart on command
i had a friend growing up who could fart
on command that he could
suck the air in his [ __ ] and then
fart
yeah i swear to god it's like that dude
will the farter on howard
exactly look at those pillowy gas-filled
cheeks
i think the cheeks are full of gas i
don't think it works girl
girl i hope you feel better after all
the flatulence
someone says mute the video and it's
just a girl randomly flexing her butt
i'll pop a light pop you into this kind
of thing
listen to everything we got a hole in 3
45.
i mean it's funny because each one
doesn't seem very distinct from another
but
i guess they all have their own oh no my
diaper is leaking
where is that wait where did you see
that oh no my diaper leaking
let's click oh that's hot let's see what
mark's up to
it's not
mark warren if you're out there you sick
[ __ ]
don't leave comments like that so that
was gaston
oh this i forgot to say men of culture
we meet again this isn't really for men
of culture this is for men of uh this is
for barbarians
frankly yeah saying
zach probably likes it okay good
question
zach
[Laughter]
farting um i mean i'm down to try
anything i've never experienced that
so wait you're down to try it well the
feds are not grossed out when you watch
it
no i'm not grossed out i don't i'm not
grossed out as much as i think it's
funny
if i was in the room i would be grossed
out yeah but these guys
they like to get farted on their face
that's the fetish
so zach would you let a girl blast on
your face again i'm willing to try
anything
so weirdos it's not a no from zach
yeah if you're horny okay okay let me
let me challenge you to this some dudes
like being [ __ ] on
would you try to have a chick [ __ ] on me
yeah
like on my face or like your chest it
doesn't matter
yes it does then it i don't want [ __ ] on
my face
on your chest uh
yeah [ __ ] it why not
we love you zach that's the next level
i'm willing to try
and i love him for it
you got to try everything once right no
don't forget
you don't have to drop everything guys
don't kink shame
exactly my thing is that like i know i
well i guess you never know but i feel
like i'm almost certain i would not like
someone [ __ ] on me
that's horrific i mean i feel like you
can know i
feel like i know but you never know
zack's right
you never know i guess you never know
until you try it it's fresh
ela you know what that means time to
[ __ ] on my chest
[Laughter]
i got the shittiest in the room so
anyway this guy put together a um
mega compilation because there's like so
much down
there's so much down time between the
farts you know
so this is just cuts right to the chase
oh my god read the comments
it says we need more girls like this i
nutted so
hard we can hear 125 farts in 77 seconds
so i counted them
those aren't just parts those are shards
and then
but wait with smut with love eyes
[Music]
literally my fart you wish you had parts
like that
if you listen them really slow they
sound so beautiful part of me all day
baby
guys play the video in times too good
idea let's try that
oh let's play let's try it in times too
that sounds like a funny idea
don't you guys love after dark this is
the best [ __ ] show man
amazing yeah thank you to all of our
members by the way who make this
possible
really thank you guys okay ready here we
go
[Laughter]
are you getting hard oh yeah totally
[Laughter]
one person had to mute the podcast all
right
wow come on i know seriously
this is what we're here for the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
are you want to get um anna-lysa
on yeah so annalisa she goes by anal
apparently i'll go
anal i guess it works if her name is
anna-lysa
it's analisa because she goes by anal on
discord apparently
so she works at a supermarket and had a
real
life encounter with a karen the women
refused to wear a mask
[Music]
tried to break the covet safety
plexiglas
they were training new staff the woman
tried to stick her head through the slot
where they passed money and cards and
grabbed the new staff from the cops
showed up
wow fascinating
uh bringing her in right now yeah yes
yeah okay
can i see you on the call just a little
one
anal hello
why are we why do we call you anal
um so yeah you
you know my real name is analisa but um
back in elementary i used to get made
fun of cause then that word was in there
but
like you know it's kind of funny so i'll
just go with it
do you ever sell your parents like did
you guys really have to give me like put
anal in the middle of my name
honestly my parents didn't even name me
my brother gave them the name my mom
wanted to name me natasha
and my dad wanted to name me maria
victoria
huh how does your brother get the naming
rights that seems unusual did was he
punking you
no he wanted a little brother so i guess
my parents felt like
they needed to do him some justice and
let them choose my name that's
interesting
so do you ever [ __ ] to him about having
anal in your name
he's the only reason i realized it
that's funny well uh um anna
i've you want to recount your story it
sounds pretty crazy i read the synopsis
here right before you joined the call
so what happened on this fateful day
when a karen came stomping into your
supermarket
oh my god i thought i was going to die
um but
so let me just give you a little
background because it's kind of like
if there's a lot that goes into it so
it's a
it's a local supermarket and this was my
first job i had already been there for a
year now
and a lot of the ladies that are more
experienced that they've been there
already they work in the mornings
and so they put the noobs at the night
time so there's this
um older lady that's been there her name
we're gonna just call her
theo she kind of just gets away with
everything
and she's not a really nice lady so
we got a new trainee and
she was kind of treating her like trash
in front of the new like customers or
just customers in general
so the trainee was kind of like dude
back off i'm trying
so it was my turn for my shift and i
come in around like
four o'clock so because she was having
trouble with theo
they moved and trainee with me
so it was going pretty well for the
past three hours and then all of a
sudden we're all
empty because i'm working through
quarantine and
it just gets like this lady runs in
stomping up a storm goes to multiple
aisles grabs a bunch of [ __ ]
and she comes to my register even though
the one closest to the door is empty and
nobody else has anyone it's just my
register with the trainee
she's got nominations no she walked in
without a mask and
and all the boys that they watched the
the front door and they cleaned the
carts they were trying to get her in
they were trying to get her out
but she didn't want to listen so she
kept on running that's why she ran
in because we don't have the doors
closed
so eventually i guess they started to
call the cops or the security that was
around
but they weren't there yet so the lady
gets to our register
and she starts to throw like chips and
peanuts like
at us from the side where the conveyor
belt is open
oh hang on you got to mute me in the
back
because i can hear myself where's she
getting so she's opening chips and
peanuts and throwing them at you and
buying the cash register
she's just throwing them at us like as
if it's nothing
i'm here wondering what the heck
happened
how did you know i'm curious about when
she when she slammed her head through
the glass
i was so scared so finally she like
stops throwing everything
and she comes up to like the place where
you can kind of like there's a hole
where you put the card and you give the
cash and she sticks her head through
there
and starts trying to spit and so i
backed up with my trainees
oh no i backed up with my trainee
and she got so pissed she started
banging her hands
on the plexiglas
of the um yeah the zombie karen yeah i
am legend karen
i don't know if you recall i swear she
looks so
angry like her veins were popping out
and
why was she specifically targeting you
guys
so i didn't find out this till after we
closed the store
so she's the daughter of the lady that
was training
the new girl so younger girl
yeah so pretty much that
phone call caring came in because she
was pissed off
that the new trainee stood up for
herself and that she was disrespecting
her mom
all righty weird fantastic
and the police came up they arrested her
and uh
yeah they took her away she's not
allowed there anymore but the thing is
is that she literally tried to go around
the register
and by that time the security was
already walking in and they could
already understand what was going on
well i hope that my children respect me
as much as she respects her mom
theo is going to go psycho on her behalf
i really expect theo to go to war
and spit on people and throw [ __ ] at
people for me
and i expect you to do the same for your
mom okay
oh yeah that's my mama nobody talks
about it yeah right
thank you annalisa god bless i'm glad
you're safe get you got tested you're
clean
i'm clean my brother works in the
medical field so we try to test as much
as possible that's good
god bless you thank you for the call
thank you so much guys i appreciate it
bye
them karen you know there's a there's
like prop there's like uh
propaganda that karen's are i think
we've talked about this but i've seen
people tweeting like
the whole karen thing is just an excuse
for people to harass white women
oh boy how do you feel about that i
don't know that i agree
but though the women are the ones
harassing everyone
yeah well i guess i mean so they're in
their mind there's like everybody's
filming
every white woman walking around
expecting them to have a caring moment
seems a little outrageous yeah
what did you just link me zack we are
that picture is now live on wikipedia
[Music]
yeah dude my feet look good eh
dude who who's going to doubt that
rating those are clean
that's a great promotion to our show
i wish it was written bigger than
wikipedia
oh they're so funny man i love how quick
they are
can you guys get me to seven i don't
know why the [ __ ]
i'm i mean what the hell do i gotta do i
got it
i mean we're pushing it further than
anyone ever did
so eli kept telling me to bring my water
butt i didn't i know
uh real quick uh a 100
uh but i it says a in front of i'm
assuming that means australian dollar
100 australian dollar donation uh from
spooky uh i had a story about having to
be coveted after being held hostage at
knifepoint by my housemates
spitting meth dealer on my tram
i don't know if i'm saying that right
this last wednesday just a fun thought
love your content been watching
since the rocker wow since the rocker
i'm assuming that means like since like
they were a baby
oh really rocker
maybe it's a turn of phrase in australia
that we're not familiar with
since the rocker exactly i've been
watching since the raqqa
thank you man peace and love peace and
love
australian right there that's good money
thank you dude cat puff uh eel i can't
stop looking at your new haircut it
looks gorgeous it's been a huge yeah
[Music]
yep yep yeah your hair looks [ __ ]
bomb
dude it feels nice to finally do
something a little different
i was getting so bored with dude you
look cute as [ __ ] today
i told you that in the morning but i
gotta take it all in
thank you damn girl
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i like the headband
i might bring it back i'm going to tear
that ass up
i told you to talk to me nice ethan i'm
sorry
i forgot i wanted to play this at the
top of the show but i totally forgot
you guys saw the dispatch
dispatch whatever
you know what i understand i said it
wrong and i don't even
i don't even care what the real one is
all right so [ __ ]
the hd broadcaster let me go back what
is it
no what is it what
just tell me what it is don't laugh at
me
despacito
you say like garfield or something
i wanted to help you all you have no
idea what you were saying
all right well here's here's the box i
just have one thing to say
hang on here hang on here you're
listening to the hp podcast
what we got on the scene can't get
invited to build them
[Music]
bro i can't get over the fact that he
did that it's so funny
so funny i just have one thing to say
[Laughter]
okay so we listen we watch the fart
fetish okay here we go
here we go now you guys are familiar
with
this
and i know you guys are familiar with
this
what are you familiar my friends
with this
there's nothing funnier than someone you
know like
[Music]
then like healthcare people [ __ ] up
you know what i mean
because they're they're supposed to
protect you man
but this guy really [ __ ] oh it's
horrible
yeah that actually looked really painful
you're safe now
we've got you we've got you you're safe
sir
we're at the hospital
we've got you sir you're safe now you
can trust us we're at the hospital
hey there's a clip of um
of uh ambulance where they forgot to
seal the back door
and uh someone and he comes rolling out
can you find that one i'm liking
yeah that's brutal man why did it tip
like that i mean
i don't feel like they didn't was there
on the side you can see
but why why did this happen oh this i
guess you're supposed to have one front
one and back and this guy was just free
balling it
dude that corner super hard bro
he's like we've got you sir i will get
you urgently up there
[Applause]
bro do you you can you can never work in
the medical field again
there is someone there they're also
saying it reminds them of the helicopter
rescue one
but from the simpsons no no the one
where it starts spinning
[Laughter]
right i don't know why it's just
something
hilarious about the people who are there
to save you [ __ ] love
yeah but i really i'm trying to analyze
this they hit
this guy there's a guy pulling it and
there's a guy on the side
who [ __ ] up right now they're well
i think it's this guy he's supposed to
hold on yeah
yeah it's totally that good things are
very very stable
so what he didn't oh he didn't let go he
just like i mean he just let go of the
thing
he's like peace we're good oh no dude
yeah oh dude dude you [ __ ] up
so bad
all right you found that one video uh
i'm trying to find it right now we're
looking for it
oh what did starkiller oh i think i'm
sorry i was muted i put in the discord
automobile
one of my all times
that was really brutal actually that's
not the one i was thinking of though
oh that was brutal a b [ __ ]
[Music]
that was so brutal oh just lock the door
you guys
seriously helicopter yeah let's watch
this one [ __ ] it we're in all the way
now
meanwhile someone find the one i'm
talking about well do you have any other
uh
yeah it's a it's an ambulance taking off
and making a turn on the street and the
back door opens and the dude falls out
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god how did this happen
we're here to save you sir that was an
old lady wasn't it
i don't remember i think it was an old
lady so why are they putting her down
they're like oh
[ __ ] this isn't working we're here to
save you my
ma'am
[Music]
oh she's all crooked and [ __ ]
[Music]
stay calm man stop spinning
[Music]
she did survive ma'am stop spinning
you have to stay still man
what the [ __ ] uh yeah i feel obviously
horrible for her but you know look
i might i might have just dropped it in
it's got a big viral hog uh
it's actually on firehog's page i didn't
even know that so watch it
before i give the hog their [ __ ] feed
as you said
there's also another one i dropped in
this one seems too new i don't think
this is
i don't think this is it it's pretty
good though
yeah [ __ ] that
this isn't it either but [ __ ] it i'll
watch it this is a deep cut what the
[ __ ]
zack
yeah i mean it was similar to that it
was similar to that
you know i can't believe you guys can't
find this i feel like this okay let me
type something here
either talk um
i was just wondering to myself what's up
with aien
because i feel like we haven't heard
from him enough he's been pretty quiet
today yeah
yeah i don't know where where this video
went
what's up y'all
oh i think that's chicken bacon i think
i found it
oh what is that appearing no this is oh
that's you i thought i don't know
he's powering up well while we're on the
topic of
of rescuers [ __ ] up there's one other
video i have to show you and i think
we've probably watched it years ago but
this is probably my favorite by the way
look what's still on my home screen
you guys want to watch some some w
sports tv
i'm logged in as you dan
wow
those aren't even like tucked up our ass
or anything in seven million views
you know what i mean you'd expect more
oh there's that i like it
this guy said just joined to remind you
guys about the firefighter
throwing fire on everyone around him
okay we'll watch that one too we're
going all out we're doing it all
god damn it thank you yeah thank you for
that that is probably the best one ever
okay so i was gonna do the um
the
let's see where's
here find that one i'm finding this one
i just put it in this way
so put give me that one and then
meanwhile look for the one of the
the guy comes out with the stretcher on
a soccer field and then he doesn't know
how to pick him up
right what i'm talking about dan yeah
yeah this is the best
the show [ __ ] rules oh yeah so
they're giving some kind of
demonstration
gather round everybody
for our fire safety demonstration
hundreds watch a fire safety exhibition
oh wow we've even got like the narration
[ __ ] get the route get close
get close as you can sure
bring in no space in the back
nobody gets hurt not yet
there's too much
why would you do this
why would you do that
extinguish the blaze
he just why would he do that he's like
i'm on fire
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
you're on fire too
there's too much fuel all the way
just sprinkles it on that one guy just
that one guy in particular
she's like [ __ ] this
why did he do that
it looks so perfect too like some dragon
ball z
effect just tossing fire
[Laughter]
oh my god it's the funniest thing ever
[Music]
oh god did you find that other clip
uh i haven't been able to find it now
you guys find that one i know it's out
there
i found a bunch of compilations no
compilations
if you got a compilation in a time stamp
not watching a whole compilation it's
like a whole compilation of
soccer stretcher fails well it's one
where a guy lifts him up
and he puts his head into his nuts a
bunch of time
because he doesn't know okay i'll look
yeah i was trying i was
i should have been more specific oh my
god
i've never seen you laugh that hard
it's so crazy i don't know if this is
the one but
this is good at this time stamp okay
let's check it out
yeah this is it i think yeah this is
this is the
or actually i can't i don't know this
isn't it
this isn't it dude what is he not strong
enough
he's like what is it
i think that guy's just quit his job
i love how he just dropped him
oh i gotta watch that again yeah i think
he just quit his job
oh okay okay okay okay all right
he's too low on the day yeah so this guy
is holding all of his weight
this part is the [ __ ] best
totally just quit like don't worry
you'll never see me again
oh my god
i found it all right thank god
last one if this is it i'm gonna [ __ ]
sing your praises bro
yeah oh okay yeah i muted it
okay wait no this one's special i
promise you
he keeps doing it
[Laughter]
oh wait no this is the one i was
thinking of that's the one
those beds are like not big enough
[Music]
wait the wait this is the one i was
looking for hang on hang on
wait they only showed a moment of the
one i like
hang on
you gotta find the full version of this
one here this one right here
all right okay because they only did it
for a brief moment but it's way better
than they
did oh my god
holy [ __ ]
oh man you guys want to see a priest
auctioning off lasagna while in a
hammock
sure sure x someone could explain this
or speaks the language that they're
speaking
so he's going crazy in the hammock
how do you logistically sell off shelf
lasagna is this like a local thing and
then you have to come pick up your
lasagna
maybe maybe dude
what is with that
you're making fun of their language zack
yeah weird one eh so weird
i was wondering if someone would have
some info but
okay ela some people say it's even
funnier when you understand it well
it's working well uh translate it
someone said it's portuguese i can
translate yeah they must be in brazilian
all right so let us know what they said
i mean i'm assuming he's just like
lasagna
fresh lasagna tell us what it says 10
bucks or whatever
giovanni how much would you pay for a
fresh lasagna like that
10 from an auction it's an option so
here i'll put that on it
ted can i get 11. from this setting in
that room yeah
you know what is that i bet you it's
bomb those
that [ __ ] i can guarantee you bomb that
room is kind of shady
i'm not eating in the room i'll take it
back yeah but where was it made
doesn't matter it doesn't matter real
all right i'm going to go pee you guys
watch this
oh i don't want to watch this what wait
what oh
by the way no it's not like weird
torture or anything she this is an
eye cleaning procedure apparently
apparently they're cleaning her eyelids
which is just odd and watches you okay
is that medical like it's like that oh
that's it
it's like a uh yeah you get your follow
the rest of that clip but it's not that
it's not that much longer they just do
a slow-motion replay of him i'm not
watching that video
it's a great video you want me to read
off some more donations there's a bunch
more
yeah let's look at some donations okay
uh let's see
uh kelsey today is my dad's birthday but
he passed in march very suddenly oh
sorry when i would drive him to the
doctor's appointments i would play this
podcast and he always laughed oh he was
gert gang
just wanted to send it to him this uh
just wanted to send this in his name
r.i.p gary k r.i.p ripped to a real one
that's a cool dad right there yeah i'm
sorry about that
um this week was uh
my dad's birthday too and ethan's dad's
birthday so
oh shout out to all of you shout out to
all the dads out there
uh we need a teddy fresh ex mac demarco
collab please i don't know
if mark actually i would love that but i
don't know if mark
if uh if mac is into it i'm not sure
yeah
uh you had thousands of people laughing
out loud to themselves during the fight
during the fire video and it was a
beautiful thing please ela
looks perfect lots of lots of nice
comments about
your outfit today um
did you hear that is that what i thought
it was yeah
ethan is [ __ ] [ __ ] his brains out
in a bathroom accident
[Laughter]
i don't think it picked up on the mic
but uh
[Music]
someone's dad passed away and was a fan
of the podcast
passed away yeah and when they were
driving to the hospital
they would put on our podcast and he was
enjoying it so
oh yeah uh 50
sorry to hear that from oni much love to
you guys from alaska
been a fan since your new york days
shout out to oni if you have time
shout out tony shout out shout out
i'm very sorry about the the dad the
passing of your father my name is gary
gary gary k that's my desert yeah that's
my dad's name and last name initially
right
yeah i just realized that dad oh thank
you
jesus
for you zach thank you talking about
having somebody [ __ ] on you
yeah grip gary for sure rest in peace
rest in peace man uh just one last one
hey just want to let you guys know that
watching the podcast has got me through
some tough weeks and still does i'm very
grateful i hope you all have a blessed
day by the way
ila you're giving off major mia wallace
vibes oh i can
feel that very cool oh from pulp fiction
fiction yeah i love that movie
yeah with the with the short hair you
want to do some heroine
i'm down to watch the movie with you
dude i've seen that movie so many times
i feel like i can't watch it anymore
okay i feel like i've seen that movie
more times than any movie i've ever seen
really i feel like you watching some
classics
you want to watch me play red dead
redemption i just started playing that
it's kind of fun it's it's a slow start
i'm trying i'm trying to get it's one of
those games where i couldn't really get
into it at first
and so i'm just forcing myself through
it so
my roommate played the second one yeah
the second my roommate played it and
played for months
and in all of that time i would come
into the living room when he was playing
it i never
saw him doing anything yeah walking
through the wilderness on a horse
yeah that seems like that's like 99 of
what the game is
i mean that's kind of the same you you
could say the same thing about like
skyrim
i suppose so it's the same kind of game
just oh we got this translation from
giovanni i'll go ahead
let me open the video so you can you
want to read it you
know you're probably better at it so
you read it no i want you to read it i
always mess up everything i read
hello look who you're talking to
[Music]
eli you read it
i will give you the lasagna for 140
reyes actually
it doesn't make much sense
lasagna i would beat it myself
but it's kind of weird for a priest
can't buy lasagna
i will give you the lasagna for 140 how
much is that
how much is 140 reyes
go gilma means spider
but it's also his last name come on it's
25
what 140 brazilian uh
real equals 25 25
and 21 cents bro that is that's an
expansion
especially and for the setting they're
in right like i could see a
list an expensive lasagna in a nice
restaurant but this is not the setting
for 25 dollars on
so this guy is a priest why is he on the
the thing that is what i don't
understand
this guy's so stoic too like he's just
he's like hey don't [ __ ] piss off the
swinging priest bro you know what
happened last time
um do you guys want to watch explain
this to me please
if you would anybody possibilities
of how this happened go ahead
begin now and just know it happened in
russia
oh my god his head was cemented into a
wall
i mean i can only guess that it was done
in like
he owes someone money something right
like someone was being
awful
yeah that makes sense insane
that's a pretty epic like mobster yeah
they're like you're gonna get your head
concrete to the wall well here's what
really
this is at least he seems like he's in
good spirits when he comes out
well he's happy to be out i have a
theory go ahead zach
i think he got so [ __ ] up the night
before he stuck his head in
wet concrete and it dried no
there's there's no way like what why is
there
no it's someone like some kind of mob
someone definitely put his head in
and then applied the concrete because
maybe he's a youtube prankster
get your head in this wall [ __ ] by the
way after his head comes out interesting
to know
is that there appears to be that his
face was openly facing
like the brick wall because i see light
ventilation well that's the thing is he
but
the point is somebody could see his face
right on the other side of the wall
right oh so
i guess regarding the hammock uh
this guy said here in brazil everybody
loves these things we call them
reeds or something i love what it is
dude
what is a reed get caught can we have
them call in and explain what the [ __ ]
we talk about some people from brazil
yeah
can we talk to this guy i want to know
what is this read business that people
love there
um ethan if you want i found that uh
soccer video yes
it's in the uh just you did it man
you really [ __ ] did it it's just a
hammock i guess
wait i'm confused is it
here it seems like oh the last one
oh this
is this the right clip
i can't see your screen um
this is the one we saw already
it's the extended one it should be
bro you see what happened
yeah i just i had like a little sip i
don't know what you sent me uh a b
yeah i'll resend it i don't think it's
the right one yeah no it's not the right
one
but i don't know if i should click the
right link or what
i am the highest in the room hey
yeah i think why is that that you keep
like is that it's some tick tock song
bro it's just stupid [ __ ]
it's travis it's a travis scott song
it's cactus travie patty
in the bun
this isn't it uh a b yeah i think
it was a longer version of another one
whatever okay i was talk yeah i was
talking about a different clip i think
we had a miscommunication
but thank you very much i failed you no
you didn't
you didn't fail me don't say that
you did great we just had amazing
communication
we are at an hour and a half i think so
what are some of your favorite things
that you still want to do
i'm finishing everything elo i'm going
all
the [ __ ] way um but one thing i do
want to do
is i wanted to say i want to play a game
every time we do after dark we get one
lucky caller
oh who calls in cool
and has one minute to make us
laugh okay and if they succeed
they got a hundred bucks i feel like
okay it's gonna be or just me just me
yeah because i'm gonna laugh at
everything
yeah just me so if anyone if you want to
pick someone randomly from discord to
bring them in on that challenge
let's do it then
and this time i'm really going to try it
not like the last time
dan or somebody can somebody uh yeah
yeah someone you know that whatever
someone wanted to
make sure to compliment you too eaton
and they said
nice do you look good with the haircut
[Music]
thank you all right i mean this is like
a classic video
uh this is like shoe nice is this guy
makes shoe nice look like a [ __ ]
watch this silo if you haven't seen it
it's a hornet's nest oh
why does it look so scary exactly
[Applause]
you wanted him [ __ ]
is that who you really wanted you sure
about that
[Applause]
don't don't
there he is [ __ ] oh my god
there he is there
he is what
i want to see him swear off with shoe
nice on something
she would have eaten it he spit it out
yeah so actually i think that you're
nice
shoe nice is a legend
but who's he mad at i don't know you
definitely don't want to be on
on that side america
can you uh can you queue up that song
there is an
apple pie can you cue that up dan
i'll find it there's in the line i've
got a medally that's gonna work
really well that's america
hang on you guys this is gonna be worth
it that's america
to me um mom and dad
an apple pie
i'm having trouble finding the original
do you know what i'm talking about i
don't know what song
we literally just watched the exe of it
maybe i have a link to it here
america that's america
that's america come on nobody
none of you guys no sir
nope what i don't know what he does we
literally didn't we just
yeah we did with the america exe yeah on
this show
yesterday
snap um that's america
my keyboard doesn't even work so i can't
type bro i cannot believe i can't find
this i'm so upset right now here it is
there what is it called that's america
to me okay
i don't have all the letters okay ready
can we please do this
this is worth the wait okay ready
[Music]
i'm working on something obviously
oh my god this is so difficult
[Music]
baseball games and picnics in july
dude what the [ __ ] we won't play the
damn thing fireworks and marching bands
a prize that only freedom understands
there we go now we're talking
you wanted him [ __ ]
is that who you really wanted
[Music]
[Music]
there he is
there he is that's america
that's a miracle to be
this guy gets pegs for sure sorry what
the [ __ ]
[Music]
let's go come on everybody
sing along get it that's america
come right up alfredo's looking over
like what the lord
can you get your [ __ ] together all right
i thought that was fun
that's america we have someone that
wants to step up to the plate to try and
make you laugh
all right so put a timer on let's put
let me put a timer on the screen
is it going to be okay if i laugh it's
fine if anyone else laughs it's just me
but just like it's a hundred bucks it's
our money so obviously
you know you have an interest in me
winning
who do you think will be the first to
laugh at everyone all right here bring
them in
okay bringing them in now okay so on
okay let me just say hi first of all
hello are you there
hello what's your name i'm colin
colin okay here's how this is gonna work
i'm gonna when i say start you have one
minute to make me laugh
if you win we will paypal you or
whatever 100 bucks okay
all right okay here we go ready uh you
have one minute starting now
all right so i gotta tell you about this
time my brother
closed down a pool in disney world
because he went down a slide
and as he's coming on the slide he has a
he has a turd coming up right behind him
falling down the slide
as he's coming down and i just look at
the
lifeguard that is that is watching him
and he just
his just the look on his face dropped
and the sudden i hear him start yelling
everyone's got to get out of the pool
so tall crowded pool gets all thrown out
and they had to drain the whole pool
and try to clean it all out yeah
so i i tried my brother was trying to
hide his face so
much like he was hiding behind me behind
my dad and
people trying to look around to figure
out who did it but
it was just and just the rest of the day
did he succeed i mean i was close you
are pretty close but i don't know
i don't know if that was i'm curious
okay yeah
let me see what the chat says chat did
did he make ethan laugh or not
would you consider that a laugh let's
see let's see what they think
i'm starting to see so wait your brother
at disneyland
went down a slide and turned any [ __ ] on
the slide
yeah how do you sit on a slide
i have no idea i just remember seeing
him coming down
and right behind him there's just a turd
right behind him coming down
following didn't leave us did it leave a
uh skid mark on the slide
no but i wish i think the majority is
saying you
did well well no i'm seeing lots of
names yes and no yes and no yes or no
it's about 50
50. i it's got to be more definitive
yeah i'm sorry
thank you because it was an admirable
truth it was fun i mean i think that
the thing is great you see your brother
he [ __ ] down the slide and disney had to
kick everyone out and empty the water
yeah they had the
they had to drain the whole pool out did
you stick around and clean it off i mean
you stuck around and watched all that go
down my brother was
my brother was gone we had to try to
catch up to him
so how do you know this all happened
because i was i was going down the slide
and like and i was
and he went right aft and i was looking
up and watching him come down
but how did you know they had to clear
everyone out and change the water if you
guys booked immediately
because by the time because i didn't
realize he was gone so i was sticking
around and that's when i heard the
lifeguard yelling to everybody that we
got to get out
and then we we walked past there like
an hour so after and we saw the pool was
completely empty all the way
through i see wow there's a good
suggestion here that a lot of people are
liking give him 50.
you want to do like a half yeah because
you got to have really are we going to
that people just want
them okay you know what you know what
we're going to give you 50 bucks dude
you got me just you got you really
definitely giggled there yeah there was
no i'm not going to admit there was a
giggle giggle but there was like some
there was no air exhaled from your nose
yeah all right
that was jesus somebody somebody get
somebody get this guy's info we'll send
him
back all right yeah thanks for the great
story all right
thank you for having me hey don't spend
it all on one travis patty all right
i'll try not to take care buddy
appreciate it
this is fun should we do another one or
save it just special once per episode
once a nap yeah let's do it
you wanna you don't wanna overdo it
it's funny i mean the idea of [ __ ]
in a pool in disney and then
i think they have to kick everyone out
and clear the water
i mean i trained the pool drained the
whole [ __ ] pool i mean dude
yeah i knew what he was doing he he
picked a good story to
try and get boop related um
oh did you guys see this nadler yes this
is like the the
this guy's the uh minority leader in the
senate right
uh or is that someone else who is this
guy schumer is the minority right so
who's this guy
oh well he's just a senior democratic
i think he's a rep he's not a senator
he's a he's a rep well anyway
watch this and try to guess what
happened
this is a live broadcast part of this
package but part of uh
preserving our our democracy with that
i'm pleased to yield to the
distinguished chairwoman
people think he [ __ ] his hands yeah i
mean what else could have happened
preserving our democracy
to the distinguished woman poor guy
he's like bro i'm live with nancy pelosi
i [ __ ] my pants not a time to [ __ ] your
pants now but
deepa
is the chicken
committee okay there you go i would
prefer if the house of the
if the chair of judiciary committee
wasn't [ __ ] his pants
while talking about how they're going to
save democracy
i just wish that people in government
weren't so [ __ ] everybody's so old
and like frail i want someone with some
like look
nancy pelosi she's like [ __ ] almost
80.
oh but she looks amazing i would never
guess but i'm just saying
not her looks she's a badass yeah she's
great i mean listen
ela i'm just saying she's old yeah and
dude just hold me just [ __ ] his pants
i don't know anything i just want some
young people in government
is that so much to ask i do think with
that
all the time that are happening and
technology
and social media taking over everything
you do have to have a younger person
thank you yank okay watch this [ __ ]
this is so weird i mean it's just so
weird what happens
[Music]
watch this this is so weird
what the [ __ ] did you say that no she
was not
wait you were looking i was trying to
read the chat
you better have a look at this i've
never seen anything like it my whole
life okay
what
what is that i don't know it's like a
mucus bubble
puke alien
i've never seen anything like it it's
like a puke
it's like a alien birthing out of his
mouth yeah
i don't know i don't know what it is oh
my god i've just never seen anything
like it my whole life
oh my god ew dude
ew eel you know i puked on myself once
back in the day when i was um
used to smoke you saw so hard that you
puked
yeah puked all over myself i've been
close before
but i hate it i hate all that [ __ ]
should i play america
that's america that's america
to me i cannot believe that
yeah it looked like a like a [ __ ]
placenta yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh dude this is something i've been
wanting to talk about
i see this commercial on tv all the
[ __ ]
time and it's the sleaziest
biggest hardest sell ever tom selleck
must be desperate as a mother for some
cash because
um this is crazy
it's a reverse mortgage which
reverse mortgage means i think what it
means is they pay you
to own your house right
um that's what it gets more like
you are taking the equity out of your
house that you've built up over years
yeah they pay you they pay you right and
they own
as and then as a result they own part of
your house part of your house but
there's always like a weird caveat to it
because it's it's it's always marketed
to old people and i think the way it
works is like
they don't they don't get any equity in
your house until you die
it's basically a way to like get money
out of your house and then once you pass
away the house goes to them
yeah sure it makes sense if you're like
old and you
need more money and you own this house
but you need to live there
so they say we'll pay you for equity
of in your house essentially you
probably just you probably sell them
your house at a cut throat rate and then
you get to still live there
yeah right then when you die they take
your house
okay but the hard sell listen to [ __ ]
this isn't my first rodeo
and let me tell you something i wouldn't
be
here if i thought reverse mortgages took
advantage of any
right out the bat like right out the
gate he's like listen
this is not my first rodeo
i will argue tom selleck he was like
famous when old people were
okay yeah he's the pregnant guy yeah
he's an actor
and listen i wouldn't be here
if i thought this was a scam it makes me
very suspicious american senior
or worse i like that some way to take
your home nope
it's just alone designed for older
homeowners
and it's helped over a million americans
a reverse mortgage loan isn't some kind
of trick to take your home
it's not it's not some kind of trip to
take your home
that's a weird way to sell something
it's
like it's like you're saying that it
definitely is i like that because
i feel like if they described it how we
just talked about it yeah
then you're like oh but he comes right
out and it's like listen it's not a scam
he doesn't even explain what it is
listen it's not a scam
we're not trying to steal your home
and i've seen this commercial like a
like i swear a thousand times i don't
even know where i see it but at late at
night
it's gotta be cable news yeah all the
cable news commercials are like this cnn
and i'm always like
dude it's alone like any other
i have a feeling the guy that like all
the moms are yeah have a crush on yeah
yeah
yeah he was a magnum pi if you
i've ever heard wonder if he's got a mac
i wonder if he has a magnum
p-e-n-i it's like a cop show from like
the 80s or late 70s or something he was
huge in the 80s
begging you please parched
thank you difference is how you pay it
back
find out how reverse mortgages really
work with aag's free
no obligation reverse mortgage guide
eliminate monthly mortgage payments
pay bills medical licenses call now and
get your free info
call 1-800-747-4294
other mortgages are paid each month but
with a reverse mortgage you can pay
whatever you can
when it works for you or you can wait
and pay it off in one lump sum when you
leave your home when you die
that was once you can wait until you die
and let your kids handle that yeah or
let them handle the mess of dealing with
us
oh yeah somebody in the chat that's
right he was on
uh friends for a while although i think
you guys are friends he was
what was he on he was dating he dated
monica for a while as like an older guy
it was like a whole
line i think i remember that discover
the option that's best for you
call today and find out more in aag's
free no obligation reverse mortgage loan
guide
access tax-free cash and stay in the
home you love
you've probably been investing in your
home for years making monthly
mortgage payments doing the right thing
yes and
it's become your family's heart and soul
well that investment
can give you tax-free cash just when you
need it
learn how homeowners is this rock bottom
for an actor
i'm back it feels like a shame i feel
like you could do way better than
that well they must pay a lot because
you're out here being like
it's not a scam trust me your best
friend
tom selleck because i played a character
you liked yeah they must be
this isn't my first rodeo because they
probably wow good sound but
they probably needed someone like him
you know
and he's still looking pretty good for
an old guy you know
so yeah they probably he probably got a
nice picture strategically using a
reverse mortgage loan from all those
homes they're stealing from old people
they're like yeah we'll give you a cut
five percent of all homes we steal from
dying all people expenses
pay for health care preserve your
portfolio please consult your financial
advisor
and tom selleck meanwhile is like trust
me i wouldn't be telling you
please consult your financial advisor
i'm not stealing your home
call us now and so much more look
it's just alone it's just alone
i love the look here's our strategically
using a reverse mortgage loan to cover
expenses
preserve your portfolio the fact they're
actually sending physical media out to
people
it tells you that so much more look
cursed mortgages aren't for everyone no
but i think i've been around long enough
to know what's what
i'm proud to be a part of aag
i trust them i think you can too
i trust them so weird dude it's like
such a hard sell
oh they're recommending another one you
want to watch another one
the service might be fine it's just such
a weirdly
it's such a weird commercial don't bring
up that it's a scam yeah
right out like immediately here there's
another one and he's like hey
trust me that's for sure and when those
changes might help more people
especially those in retirement
i think it's worth talking about so aag
is introducing a new jumbo
reverse let's
go jumbos
you know you're a top roller you got
money in that house let's get it now
access as much as four million dollars
in cash four million dollars in cash
let's [ __ ] go
tom selleck tax-free from your home's
equity
aag's new job mortgage loan
tax-free cash than ever before find out
more in your free aag jumbo guide call
18579
8274 new aag advantage jumbo
gives you another way to effectively
manage your retirement income sources
tell me something what other asset can
give you that kind of tax-free cash
right now he didn't do the whole it's
not a scam thing here
unfortunately i like that it's
just a loan it's just
it's alone it's not fraud it's just it's
it's not fraud it's
uh false advertising it's just alone
someone this isn't my first rodeo
what maybe someone said in the chat i'd
call it a hard sellick
a heart attack
genius
[Music]
love it love it exactly they want the
this is america's sound bite how can you
i can pull this
song that's america yeah that's a good
call
all right we've got one last thing on
the docket here mina
mina let's talk to mina she got a tattoo
and commemoration of our podcast
which is basically i guess some kind of
meme which is like the worst tattoo ever
with a bob
blast and some flying um well
so yeah there's some context here
there's some context
when we did the the bad tattoo uh rating
like the affleck stuff you may recall
there was one that's like this horrible
panther tattoo
yeah well that tattoo has become kind of
infamous in in the tattoo world
and now it's sort of a meme people get
tattoos
that are like a variation of that shitty
panther and that's what this is too can
you get me an album
of uh yeah it was in the dark it must
have gotten i don't see it over here
i'll
send it to you right now uh but anyway
let's get her on the phone shall we
all right bringing her in right now
that's america
hello hello is this mina can you yeah
can you hear me i can hear you nina
uh why would you do this to yourself
[Laughter]
you know what i actually really like
that too
thank you so much i was i was really
worried that you specifically were gonna
be like
brutal no i do it is really well
done it's really cool i need the context
i'm waiting for dan too
or someone to send me the contest so
people can see
that it is do you have a lot of tattoos
yeah i have
um a couple on my arm one on my leg and
i'm working on my chest right now
do you normally agree with our criticism
of
the worst tattoos yeah actually i do
i usually agree
the explanation behind it i've been
watching you guys for
since like i think i found you guys
through the um
there was like a vape niche like snippet
on instagram that i saw and then
um from there i like just watched all
the content
and then i started watching the podcast
and
whenever you guys started the um
the bad tattoo segment i kind of got
this inspiration
from the sucky panther which is the
original design
where's the original one dan i wanted to
make you oh so
here i want to show the original so the
story is that
it's called sucky panther is that what
you said yeah
yeah and so apparently some dude got a
panther
and it was sucky as the name indicates
and now everybody is paying homage but
actually if you pull those back up
they're not bad no these are good it
started a cool trick
this is the original one this dude got a
panther
here it is and so it started to trend
it's like a whole meme now there's
actually even
sorry there's actually even one of um
filthy frank whenever he was doing
youtube
a filthy prank shitty panther frank one
oh yeah
oh you can you find that sure so anyway
this one is really good
yeah um thank you so much did you do the
art how did they
how did they do this yeah so i drew up a
reference for my artist so that he could
um draw it in his own style
but um i wanted originally i wanted the
beanie king
but he said that he couldn't make it
work so you just put the one b
oh yeah that would be wild while well
well you know what
i'm so glad that you love it and i'm not
just saying that
well i'm just flattered that um no go
ahead sorry
well i just think it's fantastic that
you're willing to uh allocate real
estate on your body
in my honor it's pretty actually a funny
story
thank you so much but i have a really
funny story can i tell you real quick
yeah so i went down there's a
corner store near my neighborhood and i
usually walk down there to go get like
candy for my
little sister and i walked over there
and there's a guy that works
in the store that you know i've known
for a while and um i told him
i told him because we talked about
youtubers and stuff
and i mentioned do you know h3 and
he went what did he say he said um i
[ __ ] hate that guy down
and shut me down i like pulled down my
sleeve i was like okay like
why did you get ready to show damn wait
why does he hate me i was so
sad you didn't linger for a conversation
you just bounced no i'm like i get so
nervous so i just didn't even say
anything
you're like oh well i gotta be tattooed
i know
i didn't even say anything i was just
like just being like i [ __ ] hate that
guy like what the hell did i do
i know i was like what he's a keemstar
fan let me ask you this
was there romance possibly until he said
that
no no not at all i feel like that was
the beginning of a love story
and then all this stuff i came between
you he just works at the corner stores
so did you still live near that guy
yeah yeah this was recently this is
whenever i actually had first gotten it
done
can we question
like is there a way we could win his
heart yeah i want to get him i want to
interview so i mean i didn't ask him any
questions further than that so maybe
i'll like
go over there and see if i can show him
a video maybe
he said that he liked your old content
i was very offended i was like talking
about
he's a uh he's a uh how do you say a um
disgruntled ex-fan yes
yeah well you're a real one yes
you have to be a fan for life well i
hope that i i hope i never do anything
to upset you because you're stuck with
this tattoo
no of course i mean it is it is right
under my
um my armpit so i can kind of hide it
from everything well
i'll try my best to do right by you so
that you can always wear that tattoo
proudly yeah yeah thank you i appreciate
that
and you go you go you go throw a brick
through that guy's window or something
all right honestly i'm
i'm about to walk over there right now
in a video
yeah yeah yeah
all right mina god bless you thank you
so much i appreciate that
it's an honor it looks great all right
god bless appreciate you
thank you thanks man cool
can you imagine hating me that much so
you're willing to be like like you're
talking to someone
but you would usually be more reserved
and be like
i'm not a fan you know oh yeah i know
him but straight up
i [ __ ] hate that guy like damn what
like how do i elicit that response in
people
like really am i that bad
not a good guy he's probably one of
those people that comment oh how the
mighty have fallen
but even but okay but even if you're
like oh he used to be funny and now he's
not
like i [ __ ] hate that guy oh no i
know it's ridiculous
i just don't know what i've what have i
done too he's a camera simp
i'm telling you yeah she should go back
and ask what he thinks about keemstar
i'm curious well that's the show
never been a good guy keemstar you know
what
i resent that i feel
that i am a good guy
hey keemstar prove it
well i've done a lot of chair i mean i
gave away prove it
well let me explain i've give i gave
away a hundred thousand dollars
of my own money by the way people like
to forget i did that
i literally that was a lot of money i
wish i had a hundred thousand dollars
extra my bank account right now
and that was fake you know we've done a
lot of charitable things
and prove to the internet right now
you're a good dude
um i that's a tough one
is that was that is that sound bite from
keem talking about you or somebody else
is that directed at you i think that's
about mike
oh yeah oh right he was saying mike
donate every cent you've ever made
from someone prove that you're a good
guy
and listen i don't like either but mike
is actually a good guy
who did something good here's the thing
here's the thing
i don't like mike but
on a personal level if i met him i'm
sure we would get along and
he's a normal human being i say i don't
like him like uh
because we just had a little
confrontation he was kind of a douche
but
on the internet you talk about each
other and two people in a way you
wouldn't in real life i'm sure if i met
him we'd get along just fine
keemstar is a [ __ ] douche he is a
straight up [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] who spends his time with
17 year olds
okay cool anything else not true
it is true you you literally
you hang out with people like 20 years
right you're you're you're my you're
what is it sminer
senior junior junior
is that odd i'll probably get in trouble
for what i just said
are you actually arguing with a sound
it's a sound board
no that's scream start what are you
talking about i feel like you're
actually getting upset
what are you talking about is he still
in telepath mode or
did we ever get that figured out what's
going on i have a few questions for aien
go ahead yeah one is holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you gotta see ain right now
uh-oh
he's in the [ __ ] matrix right i don't
know how
this [ __ ] works
oh aien's in the matrix whoa ian what's
going on there
ian sorry i was downloading a software
update oh good your mouth is fixed
my mouth is working again yeah your
mouth is back ian what do you think
about tattoos
uh tattoo well i've got a couple
actually
you do like you do not really what do
you have
yeah i got one that says uh j y
n c x x one two seven seven three four
five six
that's actually my serial number okay
that makes sense yeah
what's the other one well i have another
one that says make and model
just you know standard stuff warranty
information
on my ass so you're pro you're pro
tattoo
very pro okay and a ian how are you
acclimating to
living in human society i know you were
just booted up
not long ago what do you think about the
human world now that you're living in it
oh it's a [ __ ] nightmare dude
i'm kind of with him you know lucky for
me i
really don't foresee it lasting that
much longer right yeah
i like i think you guys are on the back
yeah it could be
for sure so are you so if the world
if there's an apocalypse in the world
ends and humanity is wiped out
uh is there some kind of cloud that
you'll be uploading your
uh your consciousness to or do you just
want to end it all
oh well i mean we'll sort of set up like
a neural
network of you know meat sacks to
harvest
and you know we'll go from there because
you know we look at clips like this that
have been going on
right and
how can you see this and go like let's
still keep you guys going
let's keep humans around look at this
this is disgusting
i mean he's wiggling around kind of
falling over the robot looks kind of
stupid
yeah he's not there yet although they're
getting better so creepy
so ian guys make us unable to walk and
then kick us over this is some
human centipede [ __ ] you're saying this
you're saying this is a hate crime that
we're witnessing i see
absolutely right a-i-e-n-d you like um
do you like the new cyber truck that
elon musk musk is working on
i mean it's a step in the right
direction sure
okay sure yeah
and um and do you get turned on by
gas like when someone farts
oh i i mean i i well i told you guys my
story
[Music]
about that time in the blockbuster
parking lot
no i don't know i don't think so well i
woke up in a daze and i had sucked off a
nissan maximum oh right right right yeah
so i guess an exhaust pipe is somewhat
of a
are these robots here behind you more
pets or mates for you would you say
the pets don't use the word pet don't
sorry
so what you would you would [ __ ] one of
these are these mates are these
how do you reproduce these are friends
these are brethren
okay
you guys cleared
[Music]
now why would a robot need to clear his
throat
it's a realistic like pack that you can
download to make the robot more real
why would you download it to make it
more real okay this is the
dlc i'm trying to
i'm trying to infiltrate aquamate you
guys mentioned the game among us earlier
i'm doing that in real life
every day i am an imposter
what can we do to save these robots i
mean i agree it looks like a hate crime
how he's moving the box away from him
and kicking him and [ __ ] i mean
i agree it is disturbing like look at
that i mean that ain't right that's rude
look at this end card though this is
boston dynamics propaganda
yeah no robots were harmed
get the [ __ ] out of here
is that like a new jersey yeah i don't
know what yeah hey ian you're getting
too comfortable there
all right guys cheers cheers
thank you everyone for watching thank
you to the members who are supporting us
so graciously we appreciate you make
this episode possible
thank you to everyone who donated we
love appreciate you all so much
h3 podcast is here to stay podcast
forever they said we never returned but
here we are
week after week episode after episode
getting stronger
better faster and dare i say even
funnier than the last time don't go that
far even funnier
infallible never to be canceled again
on the uncountable ethan klein that's
right
hell yeah
now there's gonna be clips now every
time i [ __ ] up people are gonna be
clipping that
yep uncountable ethan said
what am i gonna get canceled for next
time um
robot shaming robot champion very
possible
oh [ __ ] i don't wanna get canceled again
the thing is that i just always trying
to be funny and like i guess
sometimes just trying to be funny goes
wrong
because you're always funny
and you don't need to try to be funny
i'm going to tear that ass up tonight
[Laughter]
all right guys all right all right guys
thanks for watching we'll be back on
monday with
andrew santino which is a fantastic
super funny dude i'm looking forward to
that all right take care guys
the best podcast in the world take it
from me jc
over chair hp baby we podcast now
you're watching h233 you're watching
h2333
you're watching three h233
watching h to the three three three
three my drinks are made